ce que veut faire mais ce que veut faire
Gérald armanin avec son projet de loi
immigration est-ce que vous le voterez
mais est-ce que vous le voterz mais mais
ce projet de loi est mais mais c'est une
arnaque pourquoi c'est une arnaque mais
parce qu'il y a rien dedans ce sont des
des mesurettes ben il y a pas rien il y
a des mesures pour faciliter l'exculion
justementcout j'ai posé mais mais ce
sont des mesurettes absolument pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu on ne contrôle pas
nos frontières il faut contrôler nos
frontières nationales il y a pas d'issue
haut que cela euh il faut examiner les
demandes d'asile en cent fermé à nos
frontières il y a rien là-dessus il faut
supprimer l'aide et les visas aux pays
qui refusent de reprendre nos
octtf c'est il faut rétablir la primauté
du droit national pour éviter
l'application des jurisprudences
européennes et des directives
européennes C quatre point fondament il
faut pas ramener les djihadistes de
Syrie les femmes djihadistes il y en a
80 en prison donc si vous voulez ce qui
est terrible dans ce qu'on voit c'est
que rien n'est fait pour vraiment
maîtriser l'immigration en France c'est
pas vrai le pro exte ah ben ce texte
mais ce texte est une si je votais ce
texte je mentirai au français je ferais
croire aux Français que le gouvernement
fait quelque chose alors il y a quelques
mesurettes qui peuvent être
intéressantes mais qui vont rien changer
sur le fond je vous ai dit les quatre
points C points fond on va y revenir
mais parce que Marine Le Pen hier elle a
dit qu'elle pourrait elle voter ce texte
si l'article 3 n'y figure plus vous
c'est pas votre risonnement je ne
voterai pas un texte quoi qu'il est même
si l'articleel je voterai peut-être
quelques dispositions pour pas
compliquer la vie des services de l'État
mais il faut pas mentir aux Français ce
projet de loi immigration ne traite pas
le problème migratoire français et si on
veut traiter le problème migratoire
français il faut faire les cinq points
que je vous ai dit c'est sur mon site
internet de Debout la France il y a tout
dessus alors làdessus vous êtes d'accord
avec les républicains qui eux aussi
demandent un référendum sur
l'immigration et qui eux aussi veulent
que il y a une primauté du droit
national sur le droit européen est-ce
que là du coup vous voterz juste
première question est-ce que vous
voterez leur révision constitutionnelle
ce sera le 7 décembre à l'Assemblée donc
vous voter le vous dire madame j'ai
commencé ma carrière politique mais vous
m'avez pas
répondu j'ai commencé ma carrière
politique tous les républicains votaient
le traité d'Amsterdam qui a
communautarisé la politique migratoire
céit en 1998 je venais d'être élu député
je me suis fâché avec jacirac et
Philippe segégin pourtant mon ami parce
que j'ai dit on ne peut pas transférer à
Bruxelles la politique migratoire on va
avoir un chaos c'était il y a 25 ans
alors moi je me réjouis que les
républicains découvrent que tout ce
qu'ils ont signé au niveau européen
était une catastr
je l'ai dit à chaque traité et j'ai eu
un parcours politique mouvementé parce
que j'ai osé dire la vérité donc moi je
me réjoui il faut qu'il soit à 3 % ou à
5 % pour comprendre que j'avais raison
quelle tristesse quelle gâchie si on
avait dès le début une position de
fermeté on n serait pas là donc bien
évidemment que moi je voterai toutes les
initiatives qui vont au cœur des
problèmes mais je crois que les Français
n'en peuvent plus de la politique de la
communication des fa
semblant ça sert à rien d'aller des
leçon au Moyen-Orient et de laisser la
France tomber aux mains des islamistes
c'est ça la réalité donc occupez-nous de
chez nous et là-bas soutenons Israël
quand il lutte contre le terrorisme et
soutenons les Palestiniens quand ils
sont bombardés donc vous voterez le
texte on a compris et Olivier marlex
pour le référendum puisqu'il faut bien
poser une question il propose
souhaitez-vous approuver une
modification de la Constitution pour que
la France réaffirme sa pleine
souveraineté en matière d'immigration
très bien j'en suis ravi et je dis à
Olivier marlex il va falloir continuer
parce que sur le il faut vraiment se
retirer de l'organisation de Shengen
parce que son attention le référendum ne
suffira pas si on ne rétablit pas nos
frontières nationales parce que il faut
contrôler nos frontières et ça je
voudrais que les Français comprennent
que c'est rien de montrer son passeport
pour aller à Madrid à pas à lond lond
c'est déjà fait à Madrid à en Allemagne
c'est rien puisque quand on prend un
avion on sa ceinture et ses chaussures
donc ça coûterait rien ça serait 2
minutes dans les aéroports pour montrer
son passeport et il faut être cohérent
et c'est là où les républicains ont fait
un pas je m'en réjouis mais il faut
faire l'autre pas faut rétablir les
frontières
nationales